this video is brought to you by morning
brew
you know the great resignation it is
official according to the u.s department
of labor more than 38 million americans
quit their jobs in 2021 the extent to
which people have experienced
such stress such anxiety and a ton of
burnout in the last 18 19 months covet
has done something that is forcing us to
reconsider our own purpose
it forced people to see the
unpredictability of life
many realized it's not work or at least
not their present work people don't want
to always settle for the same thing that
they might have settled for
in employment in the past now we know
that many jobs can be done remotely now
we know that there can be a higher
degree of flexibility it's just a sign
of people saying you know i don't need
this
i'm out
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
as humans living in a modern world over
99 of us need jobs that is the thing
that allows us to make a living
for the longest time the balance of
power has been leaned in favor of the
bosses and employers but in the last two
years
something interesting has happened
at january 2022 us government report
stated that over 20 million people quit
their jobs just in the second half of
2021 alone this is a global movement
employees are quitting their jobs in
record numbers it's such a noticeable
event that it has a name the great
resignation and it's a phenomenon that's
sending a clear message from the workers
of the world employers beware we know
our worth
so let's dig into what's caused this
shift how the world has responded and
what it could mean for the future
you are watching cold fusion tv
for many this pandemic provided an
opportunity for reflection
reflections in their lives careers
priorities and their place in the local
and global economy this time of
reflection came with some personal
realizations and they may affect
economies in a bigger way than one may
think
mass resignation was not the labor
force's initial response to the pandemic
in fact in the first few months of 2020
those who had stable employment held
onto it for dear life
because of the massive uncertainty
resignations in the united states fell
from 2.2 percent to 1.6
but the sharp decline was soon met with
an equally sharp correction as the world
realized that covert 19 and everything
that came with it at this point wasn't
going away any time soon
by june of 2020 resignation rates had
leveled out again and would remain
consistent
then in 2021 a sharp upward trend was
being noticed and in the first third of
the year it was clear that something had
seriously changed
in august of 2021 u.s resignation rates
hit 2.9 percent higher than it had been
for two decades
this was over four million u.s citizens
quitting their jobs
by november these records were beaten
again and a further 4.5 million people
resigned
it's estimated that almost 50 million
people would have quit during the year
and this was a global movement
according to microsoft's 2021 work trend
index over 40 of the global workforce
are considering quitting
across the globe similar trends have
been seen belgium france the netherlands
and the uk they're all seeing increased
rates of resignation but germany has
seen the highest number with an
estimated six percent of the workforce
stepping away
meanwhile in china we saw the so-called
lying flat protests which was a
rejection of being overworked india has
also seen mass quitting especially in
the it sector
and australia has had limited protests
about fair wages it's clear that people
aren't satisfied and they want a better
deal
but not all fields are experiencing the
phenomenon equally
during the heat of the pandemic
resignations are increased by the fear
of falling ill but as time progresses
low wages in the face of rising
inflation and general mistreatment seem
to be the driving forces
the service industry is most exposed to
both of these problems and are the ones
struggling to retain staff it's no
surprise then that the highest
resignation rates have been seen in
accommodation food and retail economic
analysts such as peter schiff contend
that government subsidies played a role
earlier on in the pandemic according to
the wall street journal over 50 percent
of all u.s workers were earning more
from u.s government pandemic relief
packages than they were from their work
so why would anyone choose to work for
less than what they could get by not
working
others argue that it was a necessary
step to save the american economy and
there was more at play
what we saw was that when these benefits
were turned off when workers were no
longer getting the benefits
they did not rush back to work
what does that tell you that tells me
that it's not just a function
of the benefits that's not the only
thing that's going on in the heads of
workers when they make that calculus
about
should i go back will i go back and
for what job
on the other side of the story are the
office workers
for many businesses during covert the
fastest and safest way to maintain some
version of business as usual was to
allow their staff to work from home
although zoom meetings and home offices
were originally intended as an
inconvenient but temporary solution to
safety issues covert had other plans
as months became years with no end to
the pandemic restrictions in sight some
workers became more confident more
capable and much happier with their new
remote working conditions
employees say they've enjoyed the lack
of oversight and micromanagement and
removing the daily commute to and from
the office meant more time to spend with
loved ones exercising or pursuing
hobbies and creative interests
in the us before the pandemic about one
in 67 jobs were remote
now it's about one in seven this is a
major shift in the entire workforce and
isn't something to be sneezed at
many capital cities are asking
themselves what's going to happen to all
the vacant commercial real estate
the final industry related factor is
covert induced burnouts which have
mostly affected the fields of technology
and healthcare both have seen
significant increases in resignations
throughout the pandemic and for good
reason
it's no secret that healthcare workers
were under unprecedented amounts of
pressure every day
workloads have been increased through
hospital overcrowding and due to the
nature of the virus staff shortages due
to sick leave for skyrocketing and for
many nurses doctors and support staff
this pressure simply was too much to
cope with this led to a 4.5 increase in
healthcare resignations over the past
year
on top of all of this there were also
those who weren't happy with the vaccine
mandates and chose to resign as a
consequence
there are also factors outside of
industry that play a role such as age
and career progression
according to the us bureau of labor
statistics resignation rates are the
highest among mid-career employees those
between the ages of 30 and 45
generally staff turnover rates are the
highest among 20 to 25 year olds but due
to a greater level of financial
insecurity among younger age
demographics resignations have slightly
decreased in that group in recent years
it's also been suggested that for a
number of those in the 30-45 age
demographic
covert was just the final push towards
resignation that employees had been
considering for some time
the prudential pulse of american worker
survey conducted in may of 2021 found
that 53 percent of workers would retrain
for a different industry or career if
they had the opportunity
before we continue let's take a look at
our morning brew update it appears that
the stock markets have had enough of
covert the so-called stay-at-home growth
stocks are now suffering netflix
shoplift and others are all affected but
the biggest loss is by peloton an
exercise bike company in may of 2021
they wanted to build a 400 million
factory to meet all the demand of
at-home work equipment since then 2 800
jobs have been cut and the stock has
plunged 82
needless to say those plans are now
toast if you want more stories like this
one be sure to check out morning brew
it's a daily newsletter that gets you
all the latest news in the one place
delivered straight to your inbox each
day of the week
it's free and takes just 15 seconds to
sign up so click the link below to get
started
with waves of resignation letters
flooding to the desks of employers
widespread labor shortages were
inevitable to this day it's rare to see
a business in the service industry
without help wanted signage on their
window
at first the conversation turned to
blaming welfare and laziness with
employees assuming that staff would
eventually come to their senses and all
of this would just blow over
it didn't
an anecdotal example of the way
attitudes have shifted is the rise of
followers and activity in the reddit
forum anti-work the forum is a place for
people to share their experiences of
poor working conditions expose
exploitative companies and discuss
alternative systems to the standard nine
to five in october of 2020 the page had
a modest 180 000 followers today that
number has risen to nearly 1.8 million
some news outlets such as the new york
post have even gone as far as to say
that the anti-work subreddit is partly
to blame for the great resignation
over in the u.s there have been some
strange consequences for schools due to
staff shortages the national guard has
been deployed to some schools personnel
have been given orders to drive school
buses and teach classrooms definitely an
odd site
with the labour shortage being felt
across the globe employees are getting
desperate with some offering strange
incentives to entice new staff
companies have straight up begun to
offer cash for applicants to make it to
the interview stage like one frankfurt
based tech company whose name i can't
pronounce who is offering 500 euros for
anyone who makes it to interviews
another 1 000 euros for those who make
it to the second round and 5 000 to
those who complete six months probation
in the us target and other brands have
announced that they would pay college
tuition and textbooks for new workers
who also want to pursue studies
in a win for fast food workers
mcdonald's announced in 2021 that it was
going to increase wages by 10 to combat
labor shortages but this was specified
only to mcdonald's own stores and not
the franchise restaurants which make up
the majority
when that didn't work some mcdonald's
stores in the us were offering new
employees a free iphone if they stayed
with the company for more than six
months
the hand of other employees have been
forced to increase benefit packages
offer more flexible working schedules
boost mental health programs and in some
cases the permanent increase in wages
these efforts all point to a clear shift
in power but only time will tell how
long the shift would last
some are seeing the great resignation
evolving into something slightly
different moving forward
australian treasurer joss freidenberg
believes that the great resignation will
more likely resemble a great reshuffle
and will ultimately be a positive for
the economy as people switching jobs
allows for upward class mobility
while quit rates are still quite high
some economists are predicting that a
course correction is incoming in an
interview at fortune.com behavioural
economist and professor at the wharton
school of the university of pennsylvania
iwan narenke said that covert
restrictions easing should lead to a
return to normalcy
as for low wage industries it's harder
to know how the great resignation will
affect employee employer relationships
minimum wage increases are a constant
topic of discussion and while that was
amplified by the pandemic any lasting
changes are yet to be seen particularly
in the u.s market
while inflation is also rising there is
also a risk of a wage price spiral
upwards but for now we'll just have to
wait and see
as the world adopts to a post-covert
life and billionaires continue to build
rockets for fun
public awareness of class divides will
only grow deeper because of this i think
it's safe to predict that how many
companies hire and retain staff and how
employees seek out and accept work may
just have changed for good
so this will be an interesting one to
throw to you guys
in the comments section share your
experiences with employment and work
over the past two years
tell us about what's happening in your
industry and what changes that you've
noticed
through all the comments and discussion
we might be able to get a clearer
understanding of how this is affecting
people globally though as always if you
do want to discuss this in more detail
head over to the cold fusion discord
before i go just a quick announcement
it's a long story but i basically had to
start up a new cold fusion facebook page
so if you're still on facebook check it
out the link will be in the description
i'll be posting some exclusive podcast
clips from a new podcast i'm starting up
with one of my friends i'll play you one
of those clips now to see you out
alright cheers guys have a good one also
ai companions so um if you've ever seen
the movie her yes it's got the earpiece
so um that's becoming a reality
essentially there's um an ai companion
called replica and it's kind of um
taking off uh
for younger people because people are
feeling lonely at the moment and um so
basically learned your conversation
likes and wants and talks to you and
asks you about your day and
um yeah also in southeast asia there's a
few others that are taking off and i
think it's just it's inevitable when you
just went to some black mirror [ __ ] it
is there was a black mirror episode
exactly on this where she recreated her
dead boyfriend
um
but yeah i think it's inevitable when
the ai's got to a point where it's just
good enough but you know in two years
time because in um
japan they already have um anime
girlfriends you can create
difference from anime cartoons right um
yeah you can like easily marry them as
well in some places don't know about
that well it's probably true but
yeah actually yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
cold fusion
it's new thinking